das ist der absolut damals nur noch
wenige tage am zweiten märz wird sich
die crew dragon raumkapsel von spacex
auf den weg zur iss machen die besatzung
eine puppe die nasa hat spey sexy
genehmigung erteilt und plant schon für
juli den ersten bemannten raumflug vom
boden der usa seit dem letzten flug des
space shuttles atlantis am 8 juli 2011
ja und währenddessen wird im us-geschäft
des weltraum unternehmen spacex in
sachen maß besiedlung immer konkreter
krieg zum science fiction abonniert den
kanal denn hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos herzlich
willkommen vielen macht pläne zur
besiedlung des mass nehmen immer weiter
gestalt an schon im kommenden frühjahr
also in wenigen wochen soll ein prototyp
von sasic die big fucking rocket wird
inzwischen so genannt getestet werden
und nicht nur das maske hat die preise
für die maß tickets verkündet und sie
sind sogar in einem bereich wo millionen
menschen sich an ticket leisten können
hirnmasse wurde für seine ideen damals
bei der gründung von spacex ja noch
belächelt mittlerweile ist seine firma
ein anerkannter dienstleister in sachen
welt kommen transport wissen es
vielleicht werden wir das eines tages ja
auch einmal rückblickend über seine
visionen in sachen nach bewegung sagen
hier rückte musk vor kurzem bei twitter
mit der sprache raus barry dependent on
volume parteien konnte der moving to
return ticket ist wo man denkt wenn 500
dollar und 700 dollar
lorena that most people in etwa konamis
fritz dellwo monsters and move to mars
display want musk ist also optimistisch
dass die meisten menschen in
entwickelten volkswirtschaften eines
tages in der lage sein werden sich einen
flug zum mars zu leisten je nachdem wie
die entwicklung der raumflüge voran gehe
könne man mit einem preis von 500.000 us
dollar für hin und rückflug rechnen
umgerechnet sind das 441.000 euro
eines tages könnte der preis sogar unter
100.000 us dollar also auf etwa 88.000
euro fallen wir haben ja hier praktisch
zum science fiction oft über die pläne
von ihnen masken und seiner firma spacex
berichtet derzeit ist das unternehmen
mit dem raumschiff starship beschäftigt
das etwa 100 menschen und rund 100
tonnen fracht zum mars bringen soll und
wird musk ist das mehr als nur spaß sein
plan auf dem mars eine autarke stadt zu
errichten ist seiner ansicht nach die
einzige möglichkeit das fortbestehen der
menschheit zu sichern und so ist basics
super ehrgeizig und motiviert alle
visionen seines gründers wahr werden zu
lassen
das krebsmittel für die mars besiedelung
starship ist knapp 55 meter hoch und
soll auf dem raketen träger namens
superheavy in den weltraum fliegen dass
raptor triebwerk das demnächst starship
und superheavy antreiben soll wurde erst
anfang des monats also februar 2009 10
getestet zwei sekunden lang dauerte das
ganze
das raptor triebwerk ist größer als das
merlin triebwerk und liefert so den
doppelten schub anders als bei merlin
werden auch nicht kerosin und flüssiger
sauerstoff sondern flüssiges methan und
flüssiger sauerstoff eingesetzt starship
soll von 7 raptor triebwerke ins all
befördert werden die trägerrakete
superheavy von 31 die konstruktion von
starship ist ganz besonders anders als
ursprünglich geplant wird es nicht aus
carbonfaser mischung gebaut sondern aus
edelstahl regierung macht zufolge soll
diese umstellung einen raschen und
kostengünstigen bau ermöglichen
doch von der atlas -rakete wissen wir
dass auch stahl probleme machen kann
diese waren nämlich sehr schwer und
brach so auf einer tragfläche zusammen
doch was lässt sich da nicht reinreden
die neue starship rakete werde wie
flüssiges silber aussehen so maske
wörtlich demnach soll die hoch ganz
politur als eine art cool faktor wirken
und die entstehende hitze reflektieren
dazu schrieb bei twitter am 31 januar
2009 10 zu bequem ein confident that
stainless steel schulleiter wenn etwa
ans aluminium abgabenfrei because of
strength of the world championship
need for sharing übersetzt also in etwa
so viel wie ich bin optimistisch dass
ein solches raumschiff aus edelstahl
leichter sein wird als aus aluminium
oder kohlefaser und zwar wegen seines
stärke gewicht verhältnisses der
temperaturbeständigkeit und des
niedrigen bedarfsanmeldung willig ist
auch der konkrete plan wie das starship
raumschiff vor dem verbrennen in der
atmosphäre von erde und mars geschützt
werden soll
was schätzt dass starship mit 30.000 577
kilometern pro stunde durch die mars bzw
erdatmosphäre eintreten könnte dabei sei
die unterseite seines raumschiffes einer
temperatur von rund 1100 grad celsius
ausgeliefert und tatsächlich ist das
heiß genug um die staatsregierung zu
zerstören und so sieht musk ihr
keineswegs tausende keramikfliesen wie
sie etwa von der nase eingesetzt werden
stattdessen setzt basics darauf
treibstoff der rakete durch winzige
löcher bluten beziehungsweise schwitzen
zu lassen
dabei entsteht eine flüssige schicht die
zu einer abkühlung führen würde heißt
also im klartext der raketen körper
würde sich bei der landung selbst
abkühlt und zwar mit flüssig brennstoff
musk stellt sich eine art edelstahl
hitzeschild vor dass somit nicht nur für
abkühlung sorgt sondern zudem auch noch
die stahlkarosserie stützt ein stück
weit kann man diese art von kühlung mit
der kühlung von säugetier haut
vergleichen
der schweiß wird aus den poren
ausgestoßen um einer zu hohen
körpertemperatur entgegenzuwirken
doch auch in der raumfahrt ist dieses
konzept nichts neues schon die nase hat
damit vor jahrzehnten experimentiert und
hier hat sich des öfteren gezeigt dass
es probleme geben kann und zwar mit
löchern im hitzeschild die blockiert und
verstopft sind
ein ausweg könnte es beispielsweise sein
methan als kühlmittel zu verwenden oder
deutlich mehr poren anzubringen
unabhängige luftfahrt expertinnen und
experten bezweifeln allerdings ob diese
ideen von mast tatsächlich umzusetzen
sind denn nicht nur der 1 und sinkflug
sondern vor allem auch die landung
bedeutet eine riesige herausforderung
manche experten experten zufolge ist die
landung eines raumschiffes auf dem mars
etwa 100 mal schwieriger als die mars
landung eines autos
roboters das ist alles noch
zukunftsmusik aber das hier findet jetzt
schon statt die nasa hat den ersten
testflug der space xq dragon -kapsel
genehmigt schon am 2 märz soll die
falcon 9 rakete die kollegen zur
internationalen raumstation iss schicken
und die kapsel soll am tag darauf
andocken hier werden allerdings erst
einmal keine astronauten astronauten mit
an bord sein sondern nur eine
lebensgroße puppe
klar ist so also bemannte missionen
rücken in greifbare nähe
und zwar in sehr greifbare laut dem plan
der nasa sollen noch in diesem jahr
menschen mit einer space extrakte ins
all befördert werden und zwar im juli
also ziemlich exakt 50 jahre nach der
ersten mondlandung mit zwei astronauten
beziehungsweise astronauten an bord
maximal sieben personen kann die
raumkapsel dragon transportieren am 8
märz soll die kapsel dann wieder zur
erde zurückkommen dazu bild gerstmeier
von der nasa wir sind bereit für den
schritt wir sind bereit für das andocken
um 8 uhr 45 deutscher zeit soll der
testflug mit der bezeichnung demo an am
zweiten märz also kommenden samstag
losgehen der absolute hammer
genauso übrigens eine kolonie auf dem
mond dafür hier klicken unbedingt
anschauen und den kanal von raum zeit
lockt der zukunft abonnieren bis dann
bleibt dran